größer als stonehenge archäologische
sensation ja das ist es aufgespürt wurde
ein gigantisch großes schacht system in
der nähe von stonehenge und das erlaubt
spannende rückschlüsse auf das leben der
menschen in der jungsteinzeit wir gehen
dieser nachricht jetzt mal so richtig
auf den grund also mehr spannende
hintergrundinfos jetzt bei pixum science
and future gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und activity glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
pixum gibt es jetzt übrigens auch als
podcast für unterwegs sie links spotify
und apple podcasts sind unten in der
video beschreibung
es ist tatsächlich ein absolut riesiges
steinzeit monument das jetzt in der nähe
des bekannten stonehenge aufgespürt
wurde dabei dachten fachleute lange zeit
dass gerade diese region gut erforscht
seit falsch gedacht dafür ist die neue
entdeckung umso spektakulärer denn die
überreste gehören zu einer gigantisch
großen kreis anlage um die große
steinzeitlichen siedlung darin walls und
sein mut hänsch hierbei handelt es sich
um ein handy monument das nur rund drei
kilometer südwestlich von stonehenge
liegt und möglicherweise sogar vor
stonehenge selbst errichtet wurde kurz
zur erklärung der begriff hänsch meint
an sich eine tor artige struktur
fachleute bezeichnen damit bauwerke aus
dem neolithikum also der jungsteinzeit
oder neu steinzeit es handelt sich meist
um runde flächen meist mit einem innen
liegenden graben der von einem erdwall
begrenzt wird klar ist stonehenge im
südwesten englands ist das wohl
berühmteste bauwerk in europa aus solche
riesig großen stein die steine werden
auch als monolithen bezeichnet es
handelt sich um sogenannte bausteine aus
rhyolit und dohle rät also vulkanischem
gestein das unter anderem in wales
vorkommt sagen zufolge sollen hier
zwischen den kreisförmig angeordneten
stein magische kräfte wirken die
steinzeitmenschen hatten sie vor rund
2500 jahren so angeordnet dass der stand
des mondes und der sonne im laufe der
jahreszeiten verfolgt werden kann so
konnten beispielsweise sonnen und
mondfinsternisse mit hilfe der steine
vorhergesagt
die anordnung der steine im bezug auf
die sonnenbahn am himmel liegt nahe dass
die menschen damals sehr genaue
astronomische kenntnisse hatten davon
zeugen so genannte teil steine und
linien die auf den sonnenuntergang vor
der wintersonnenwende und auf den
sonnenaufgang vor der sommersonnenwende
hin weil mittlerweile weiß man dass
diese berühmten steinkreise von
stonehenge nur ein kleiner teil sind sie
gehören zu einer großen ritual
landschaft die bereits vor mehr als 5000
jahren von menschen errichtet wurde und
laut ansicht zahlreicher fachleute bis
in die bronzezeit genutzt wurde
forschungsteams haben hier neben den
steinernen und hölzernen kreis anlagen
auch astronomisch ausgerichtet die
gräben und wälle aufgespürt außerdem
auch grabhügel und andere bauten die nun
neu aufgespürte kreis anlage hat einen
durchmesser von zwei kilometern in der
aktuellen veröffentlichung ist die rede
von mindestens 20 schichten die jeweils
bis zu fünf meter tief sind und einen
durchmesser von bis zu 18 metern
aufweisen
der archäologe wolfgang neubauer aus
wien betont dass wir es hierbei mit
einem zitat um der größten und
komplexesten steinzeitlichen monument
die bisher entdeckt wurden zu tun haben
andere fachleute werden die entdeckung
auch als erster beweis dafür dass die
sehr frühen gemeinschaften methoden zum
zählen entwickelt haben
die sorgfältige positionierung kann
demnach nur durch das abzählen von
hunderten von schritten erfolgen
die neu entdeckten gruben wurden alle in
regelmäßigen abständen zueinander
angelegt und bilden somit zwei
teilabschnitte eines großen kreises
dieser schließt wie bereits angedeutet
darin walls und seine stein reihe ein
nach ansicht der forscher des hippen
landscape projects enden diese gruppen
von ihrer machart er den bereits
bekannten ritual gruber stonehenge und
auch anderen prähistorischen städten die
entdeckung hat sogar das forschungsteam
selbst überrascht so der wissenschaftler
vince gaffney der in der studie
beteiligt war
die größe der gruppen und des ganzen
kreises umdeuten walls ist beispiellos
diese struktur ist signifikant größer
als jedes vergleichbare prähistorische
monument dass wir in großbritannien
kennen spannend ist vor allem die frage
aus welcher zeit die gigantische kreis
anlage stammt die analysen der fachleute
lassen darauf schließen
dass die gruben aus einer ähnlichen zeit
wie die anfänge von stonehenge selbst
stammen aus der zeit um 2500 vor
christus ausgehoben wurden die schächte
also vor 4500 jahren möglich wurde die
altersbestimmung mit hilfe der
sogenannten c14 datierung in der
fachsprache ist auch von der sogenannten
radio kohlenstoff datierung die rede
hierbei geht es um den zerfall eines
bestimmten kohlenstoffisotops hinzu
kommt dass die vorstände die gruben
keineswegs leer vorgefunden haben manche
enthielten steinwerkzeuge und knochen
die wohl aus der zeit stammen in der die
schächte selbst wohl auch geschaffen
wurden in einer weiteren gruppe fanden
die fachleute objekte aus der bronzezeit
demnach wurden diese bauten sogar noch
bis in die zeit von 2200 bis 800 vor
christus genutzt also mehrere hundert
bis tausend jahre war
zudem wurden weitere entdeckungen
gemacht möglich wurde dies durch
verschiedene geophysikalische analysen
die auf kleinere anomalien in
regelmäßige anordnung im untergrund
schließen lassen möglicherweise sind die
löcher in denen vor langer zeit einmal
pfosten aus stein oder holz befestigt
wurden dazu heißt es in der aktuellen
studie des internationalen
forschungsteams wir schließen daher
nicht aus dass es innerhalb des gruben
kreises einen intermittierenden inneren
pfosten ring gab
diese neuen ergebnisse sind unter
anderem auch deswegen so besonders war
das gebiet um stonehenge eigentlich als
archäologisch stark erforscht die große
frage die über allem steht wozu diente
dieser gigantische gruben ring umdenken
wollen die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus dass er
gleich zwei funktionen erfüllte aber
erstmal stonehenge stonehenge selbst
diente als ritueller ort und grabstätte
doch erst vor zwei jahren gelang es
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern genaue details zu
erfahren dazu der forscher christoph
schneck aus brüssel
trotz mehr als einem jahrhundert
intensiver forschung wissen wir nur sehr
wenig über die menschen die in
stonehenge begraben wurden schon in den
1920 er jahren hat man die verbrannten
überreste von bis zu 58 personen dort
entdeckt das macht stonehenge zu einem
der größten neolithischen graf städten
grossbritanniens die aschen und
knochenfragmente konnten in den
sogenannten orgs aufgespürt werden so
wird ein kreis aus 56 löchern bezeichnet
in denen zunächst holzpfosten und später
dann die blausteiner aufgestellt
worden waren doch wer genau wurde dort
bestattet und woher kamen die menschen
durch die einäscherung waren die meisten
hinweise darauf verdichtet worden
doch dem team um den forscher christoph
schmidt gelang es dennoch diesem rätsel
auf die spur zu kommen und zwar mit
hilfe von physikalischen methoden
konkret analysierten die fachleute die
knochenfragmente von 25 toten es ging
ihnen hierbei vor allem um das
verhältnis von strontium isotopen denn
diese geben hinweise darauf wo die
personen gelebt haben müssen
so konnten die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler analysieren aus welcher
region die nahrung stammte die die
menschen in den etwa zehn letzten jahren
ihres lebens zu sich genommen hatten und
nicht nur das denn noch pflanzen
speichern die strontium signaturen
umgebung im gewebe ab so konnte das
forschungsteam außerdem auch erkennen
woher die menschen damals das holz für
die einäscherung der toten auf getrieben
hatten
letztendlich kamen die vorstellen auf
ein äußerst überraschendes ergebnis
viele der toten stammten nicht aus der
region um stonehenge es handelte sich
bei mindestens zehn der 25 toten nicht
um einheimische die analyse offenbarte
dass sie von weit gekommen waren die
isotopen signatur ihrer knochen
entspricht den stream werden die für den
westen von wales charakteristisch sind
hier also etwa 200 kilometer von
stonehenge entfernt müssen diese
menschen die später dort begraben wurden
also bis kurz vor ihrem tod gelebt haben
möglicherweise handelt es sich bei
diesen toten sogar um die erbauer des
steinkreises dazu heißt es in der nature
studie aus dem jahr 2018 das deutet
darauf hin dass die menschen aus den
walisischen presley bergen nicht nur die
blausteiner herstellten sondern dass sie
die steine auch nach stonehenge
begleiteten und schließlich dort
begraben wurden
diese ergebnisse unterstreichen die
bedeutung überregionaler verbindung für
die konstruktion und nutzung von
stonehenge für die sowohl material als
auch menschen über weite strecken bewegt
worden
die wissenschafts community weiß bereits
seit längerer zeit dass die bausteine
des äußeren mega lied ringes aus dem
westlichen welt stammen doch ein
weiteres geheimnis um die entstehung des
berühmtesten megahit bauwerks europas
konnte bis heute nicht wirklich gelüftet
werden wie konnten die massiven steine
von stonehenge transportiert und in
position gebracht werden
experimente legen nahe dass die menschen
damals hölzerne schlitten benutzt haben
zudem war eine große anzahl an arbeitern
notwendig um die gigantischen brocken zu
bewegen hatten diese sich damals von
großen mengen schweinefett ernährt lange
zeit war man davon ausgegangen
denn vor ort wurden immer wieder
steinzeitliche tongefäße gefunden mit
rückständen forschungsteams hatten diese
bis vor kurzem als belege für große es
gelage interpretiert die
wissenschaftlerin lisa-marie sillitoe
aber ist skeptisch warum findet sich so
viel schweinefett in den gefäßen wenn
die an der fundstelle ausgegrabenen tier
knochen doch darauf hindeuten dass die
meisten schweine damals am spieß
gebraten wurden und nicht zerkleinert
und in töpfen gehabt sie geht
stattdessen davon aus dass in den großen
gefäßen teilt gelagert wurde der dann
als schmierfett genutzt wurde diente das
fett also als schmiermittel für die
schlitten der erbauer von stonehenge
dazu die archäologen die samuel eto'o
eine solche interpretation würde die
schlitten theorie zum transport der mega
lette untermauern
als hinweise auf diese schlitten theorie
sieht sie auch die tatsache dass das
fett an scherben gefunden wurde
die von großen kübeln stamm und
keinesfalls zu geschirr passt das zum
essen oder kochen genutzt wurde
doch der letzte beweis für diese theorie
fehlt und so müssen weitere funde her um
diese spekulationen ein für allemal zu
beenden auch zu den großen gruben ring
umdeuten walls der es jetzt aufgespürt
werden konnte gibt es reichlich
spekulationen wozu er wirklich diente
kann bislang nur gemutmaßt werden doch
das internationale forschungsteam geht
davon aus dass er eine doppelte funktion
erfüllt hat zum einen hat er wohl die
außengrenzen der rituellen anlagen
markiert zusammen mit der stein reihe
hat er den menschen damals wohl außerdem
den weg hinein ins zentrum der anlagen
gewesen dazu vince gaffney während der
aktuellen studie beteiligt war
diese funde demonstrieren die bedeutung
des handys von deuten wolz und die
komplexität der monumentalen strukturen
in der landschaft von stonehenge die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sehen ihre entdeckung als einen weiteren
beleg dafür wie stark der glaube in der
jungsteinzeit war und auch wie sich
dieser zusammen mit den kosmologischen
vorstellungen der menschen in den
damaligen bau
werken widerspiegelt die fachleute sind
optimistisch dass sie schon bald weitere
spannende entdeckungen machen werden vor
allem details zu den resten des inneren
rings und den ritual gruppen könnten
weitere erkenntnisse ermöglichen bislang
konnten erst 20 gruppe aufgespürt werden
woche nach ansicht der forscher könnte
sich insgesamt sogar um 30 stück handeln
der wissenschaftler
nix ne show fast das folgendermaßen
zusammen als der ort an denen die
erbauer von stonehenge lebten und
feierten istanbuls der schlüssel zur
enträtselung der tieferen geschichte der
stonehenge landschaft diese erstaunliche
entdeckung gibt uns neue einblicke in
das leben und den glauben unserer
steinzeitlichen vorfahren wie aber haben
damals die menschen diese riesige
steinblöcke aufgerichtet der gag das
kann sogar ein mensch allein und in
diesem video ist es zu sehen nicht die
beste qualität aber mega spannend der
titel amazing video-clips trendy tonn
blog bei hand also anklicken und
anschauen und krieg zum science im
future diesen kanal ihr unbedingt
abonnieren damit er nie mehr was
verpasst bis dann bleibt dran